- All right, thank you so much.
I'm gonna begin with a statement.
Agents are the new storefront,
so discovery is shifting.
Thanks. Hold your applause please.
Discovery is shifting to
GenAI-assisted agents.
So in 20 minutes I'll show you
two modes of agentic commerce
and how AWS plus Stripe are
helping to make payments
instant and secure and trusted
in both of those modes.
So really quick, let's jump
right in into a lightning talk,
and there we go.
All right, so 30 seconds on Stripe.
Stripe is a financial platform.
Think of us as the financial
infrastructure of the internet.
So basically we do a lot
more than just payments.
Consider us to be
programmatic money movement.
So we like to think of ourselves
as the AWS of payments,
but we do a lot more than just payments.
So as you can see here,
we obviously accept money globally
in many different countries.
We can automate revenue with,
you know, recurring payments
with our billing product.
We can automate tax calculations,
reporting, and data.
We power lots of
marketplaces in the world,
from DoorDash, to Instacart,
to Lyft, many, many others.
And we actually have a lot
of banking as a service,
money management offerings such
as Stripe issuing, capital.
We're also very market
leading in stablecoins.
So think of us again as
programmatic money movement,
financial infrastructure
to solve use cases across the board.
We're very horizontal in
how we approach things.
And we're very proud of
our partnership with AWS.
So we have competencies in
everything you see here,
retail, media and entertainment,
travel and hospitality, insurance,
as well as focused on ISVs as a vertical.
And this partnership basically
really comes to fruition in life,
when you think about the amount of uptime
and availability that we drive
through both AWS' really
fantastic cloud infrastructure
and our very talented
engineering team at Stripe.
We drive five nines of
availability consistently.
We just completed Black
Friday, Cyber Monday,
moved I think close to $40 billion
and had six to seven
nines of availability.
So we're very proud of the
fact that the combination
of AWS plus stripe serves
4 million plus customers
in a very scalable, reliable way.
And these types of solutions
drive real revenue for customers.
So in adding Stripe's
optimized checkout suite,
we can generate on average close to 12%
of top-line revenue uplift.
That's a huge number when
you really think about it.
And we can modernize and optimize
and drive efficiency
through 30% faster launches
through Stripe's innovation in API layers,
in developer SDKs, toolkits,
we have some of the best
documentation in the industry,
and we have a unified API.
So we're very friendly to drive efficiency
through innovation through
our developer community.
And finally, reducing risk.
So we have many, many fraud data models
that I'll talk about,
that are powered by again, the combination
of Stripe engineering
and AWS infrastructure.
So earlier this year we launched
the world's first
payments foundation model.
It's trained on literally tens
of billions of key signals.
Think of it as using the
breadth of the global economy
to train an AI model.
So if you know anything about
vector databases or vector spacing,
it uses high-dimensional vector space
to quantify things like different clusters
and what these clusters
mean to each other.
So payments that share
similarities, for example,
that come from the same
country, or from the same card,
or that are positioned
closer geographically,
from the same bank,
we can cluster this information
and use it to be very predictive
in how we prevent fraud
and bring other solutions to market.
Payments from the same
email address, for example.
These are very important data points
to build into vector
spaces and to cluster.
So in using these solutions,
we've driven $1.4 trillion
of annual payment volume
last year in 2024.
92% of cards using this
payment foundation model
have been seen before.
So again, think of it as an AI model
that's just trained on
billions of data points.
So we can become very predictive
and actually look at a
transaction start to finish,
and instead of being reactive to it,
actually be proactive
in eliminating fraud.
So we've had millions of companies
that have leveraged these
products and solutions.
Now, this payments foundation
model drives the entire
end-to-end experience,
from the checkout, to authentication,
to fraud prevention with
radar, card testing,
all the way across the board,
refunds and disputes,
the payments foundation model is key
to delivering value end to end
in the entire payments lifecycle.
So some real-world statistics,
95% of card testing attacks
have been detected in real-time
using this payments foundation model.
21% improvement over prior methods.
Though again, very key that
we're instead of reacting,
we're being very proactive
using this foundations model
to prevent fraud.
Things like smart disputes.
So if you're ever gonna dispute a charge,
it could be 10 to 15, 20
pages of documentation
that you have to submit.
Smart disputes is a way
that we're using GenAI
to generate this paperwork,
generate everything,
submit it automatically,
automated end to end.
And so DoorDash implemented it
and had a 10% reduction
in chargeback costs,
which you can imagine for a
company the size of DoorDash,
this was a very significant
amount of revenue.
Vimeo and Squarespace,
13% increase in chargebacks recovered.
So again, automation and AI
can be used in every aspect
of end-to-end payments lifecycle,
including including
even fighting disputes.
So really quick to wrap up,
optimized checkout suite,
it boosts revenue by creating frictionless
checkout experiences for your customers.
We also have a one-click digital
wallet called Stripe Link.
You can go to link.com,
sign up for an account.
Basically think of this as a
phone-agnostic digital wallet.
It's not Apple Pay, it's Google Pay,
it competes with those from the standpoint
of what it delivers,
but it's available to you no
matter what device you use,
no matter what browser you use.
So Stripe Link is definitely
a one-click wallet
that powers a lot of
frictionless checkout experiences
for us.
So let's jump into the topic
at hand, agentic commerce.
So I promised you we'd talk about
two modes of agentic commerce.
There's actually three
models that exist today.
Business to agent, otherwise known as B2A,
agent to consumer, A2C, and then A to A.
I'll briefly touch on A to A,
because it is more of a future model.
Think of it as a world where
you've got an autonomous agent
from the buyer's perspective,
negotiating with an autonomous agent
on the seller's perspective.
And there's no human involved
at all in the checkout.
So you're basically having
an agent shop on your behalf.
The seller has an agent
representing them on behalf.
You're using policy engines and logic
to come to a conclusion.
That's a future use case
that we're working on.
But we have already launched
real live solutions today
in the first two use cases.
I'll start with business to agent,
and this is participating
in agentic channels.
So quick show of hands,
who here has used any AI
surface to try and buy something
or at least get a recommendation
to shop for something?
Wow! Okay.
So our stats show one out of four,
and that was more than half,
just roughly scanning the audience.
So very sophisticated audience here
that's used AI for shopping.
So the key thing that
we wanted to talk about
is that's one channel,
AI being the new search,
as I mentioned earlier, AI
being the new storefront.
And then we have AI-powered advisors,
which is agent to consumer.
We'll also talk about
that use case as well.
So business to agent,
what we're seeing is an emerging
ecosystem between buyers,
AI agents or orchestrators,
and merchants and businesses.
So businesses want their products
to be discoverable in
these AI chat surfaces.
And buyers want a frictionless, very safe,
secure checkout experience.
Basically payments is
the one layer of trust
that cannot be compromised
in agentic commerce.
Think about giving an agent
your bank account information
or your credit card and saying
"Go out and shop for something,"
that may not be the best idea, right?
So we wanna basically build something
that's fast, secure,
reliable, fraud-proof.
And so this is the ecosystem
that we're working with.
So we've partnered with
all the AI companies
that you see there in
the center of the screen.
And again, we're
laser-focused on making sure
that this new ecosystem,
this new way of purchasing
is safe, reliable, and secure.
So what have we launched?
We launched this in late
September at our US New York tour
it's called Agentic Commerce
Protocol, ACP for short.
And it's an open-standard
Apache-2 licensed community-driven,
can be used by any AI surface.
So we launched, we
co-authored it with OpenAI,
but it is available to be
used on Perplexity, Gemini,
Microsoft Copilot, X, Meta,
all the ones that you saw
on the previous slide.
And the way to think of it is,
the problem that we were trying
to solve by giving an agent
a virtualized debit card and
go out and complete a purchase,
is a very difficult problem.
So in the past we tried
using things like browser automation,
and what we realized is that
agents are not really very good
at trying to figure out a
human-readable checkout.
So agents are very probabilistic,
and you get different outcomes every time.
So it could go to the same human checkout
and figure it out in five seconds,
or go to that same human checkout
and take 10 minutes to figure it out.
So we launched an experience
similar to that with Perplexity
and we learned a lot and evolved,
and basically came back
to the drawing board
and said, "Okay, what we
need to do is make a way
of making these human-readable
checkouts machine-readable.
So we need to create an abstraction layer
and bring that human checkout to the agent
in a way that the agent
can be successful."
And what agents are really good at
are deterministic outcomes.
Agents can hit an API
and make a consistent API call every time.
So that's basically the thought model
around what we were trying to solve.
And so what we brought
to market is a protocol
that again makes a human-readable
checkout machine-readable.
And then if you wanna be
discoverable as a business
in these new machine-readable checkouts,
you have to make your product
catalog machine-readable,
and you have to feed your product catalog
straight to the agents.
So we have to publish
protocols, product feed specs,
delegated payment specs.
There's a lot of documentation
that I'll share with you
at the end of the presentation.
But that was basically what
we were trying to solve.
And I get a lot of questions about
what's the difference between AP2,
which Google launched
two weeks prior to ACP,
what are the differences?
And so basically AP2 is
a principles framework.
There's a lot of really good
thought leadership from Google
and a lot of partners that
went into developing AP2.
Stripe participated somewhat
at the beginning of those conversations.
But Stripe takes a little
bit of a different approach
in that we like to build things,
and we like to basically get
it launched out in the market.
We like to innovate with design partners
and launch something live, learn, iterate,
and evolve from that,
and then let the protocol mature
as it's being delivered out in the wild.
So we basically two weeks
after AP2, launched ACP
in co-authorship with OpenAI.
And part of the technology
that we had to solve for
was shared payment tokens.
And I'll talk a little bit about
shared payment tokens coming up.
But we are live today on Etsy,
and I'll show you an example.
And we're implementing
with Walmart and Shopify,
many other large big box retailers.
So this is a live solution
that we're talking about,
it's not a principles
framework, it is basically live,
and something that we launched.
So what is a shared payment token?
Think of an example of giving
an AI agent your credit card
and you say you wanna
buy a model airplane,
and it hallucinates and
tries to buy a real airplane
and drains your bank account.
So this is a scenario,
a nightmare scenario
that we do not wanna
embrace in agentic commerce.
So you have to have
something called guardrails,
which is basically a budgeted amount
that the agent cannot exceed.
So think of a shared payment
token as like a Russian doll
of layers of logic around a payment method
that's been tokenized.
So you've got your payment
method on file, Stripe Link
or like your Visa card.
And then you've clicked
on OpenAI ChatGPT saying,
"I wanna buy this model
airplane, it's $5."
And the shared payment token
is instantly minted at that point
and gives you a $5 budgeted amount,
and it cannot exceed that amount.
And also inside this logic
layer is fraud signal.
So if this card has been used previously
in card testing attacks,
we'll pass that signal to the merchant.
This is a very important
part of the protocol
is we have to make sure that
these extra layers of logic
are included as part of
the shared payment token.
So this is live today.
You can take out your phones
right now if you want to.
You can make history
and be one of the world's
first agentic shoppers.
I've bought many things for my dog
as I do these demos on stage.
But it's very, like I
said, you can make history.
This is something you can basically
go into ChatGPT right now and say,
"Buy me some dog treats on Etsy."
You'll find some that say visit,
which means they have not adopted ACP,
but interestingly, you'll
find some that say buy.
So you can click on buy
and actually complete that
purchase inside the chat session
while never leaving that chat experience.
So the goal is OpenAI wants
you to stay in OpenAI,
get these hyper-personalized
recommendations.
It's gonna really get to
know your dog over time,
like what treats it likes,
what size, you know, costumes
it likes for Halloween.
All of the above.
Getting those hyper-personalized
recommendations
are what the GenAI agents are all about.
But we also wanna make this a safe, fast,
secure payment experience
that meets you at the
point of inspiration.
OpenAI was very clear with us
where they said we do not
want the user leaving the site
to complete the purchase.
So four minutes left, we're
gonna talk about mode two.
Mode two is AI stylists or what
we call agent two consumer.
So some retail brands
do not want to give up
all modes of discovery to
these external AI agents.
Not everybody wants to sell
things in ChatGPT, right?
Luxury brands, you know, hotels,
there's lots of use cases
for agent to consumer.
Some of these have already been launched
and are available out in the wild today,
you may have seen Amazon Rufus,
which is an onsite AI-powered assistant.
So again, you're using GenAI
to optimize the experience.
You're still getting
these hyper-personalized recommendations,
but you're just not using ChatGPT
or Perplexity as your front end portal.
You're actually going to an
onsite branded experience.
Walmart has Sparky, Ralph
Lauren just launched Ask Ralph.
You see I've got some nice
quotes there as far as like
where the industry is heading
for agent to consumer.
And the really important thing is Stripe,
we launched this at Stripe Sessions
earlier this year in May,
we have an onsite shopping advisor.
we have a reference architecture
that we've built with AWS
that allows any business to implement
their own Ask Ralph, or Sparky, or Rufus.
So we've worked with some major brands
in using AWS GenAI frontend.
Bedrock, trained very
well on knowledge bases,
product catalogs, guardrails.
So a lot of these AI agents
that have been released out in
the wild are not really good.
Rufus is really good, Sparky is good.
There's a few good ones.
We've got since we've built with Bedrock,
built in guardrails.
So you cannot make these
agents go off the rails
and do something unpredictable.
For the architects and
developers in the crowd,
this was my reference architecture
that I built for the AI stylist,
and you can see the Stripe
interaction is a clear API call.
So you don't have to use
shared payment tokens
if you're making a direct API call
from an onsite shopping assistant.
Stripe also has an MCP server.
So you can actually call
our MCP server directly,
generate what we call a payment link
to complete the transaction.
I've got Lambda functions that
we can talk about offline.
Meet me in the corner after the session
if you wanna talk about any of this.
But basically you can interact
directly with Stripe's API,
or our MCP server, or
our agentic commerce SDK,
to build out onsite payment experiences
that are powered directly at that level.
So with the last minute, I'll
open it up for any questions.
You can also scan the Q and A,
I'm sorry, the QR code here.
Main thing is you can go
directly to agenticcommerce.dev
and see the protocol that
we published with OpenAI.
We have a GitHub repo.
We're very encouraged
to make this an open community
developer-led experience.
We've realized that at Stripe,
we use this talking point a lot.
We haven't won yet. Okay?
We released thus protocol,
it's been very effective so far.
But there are so many more
use cases that we wanna talk
to our merchants about,
that we wanna work with
our developer community
to build this out
and make it more mature
and evolve over time.
So with that, I am 20
seconds away from being done.
Any five second questions?
All right, well, thank you so much.
I'll be hanging out after the show
if you have any questions.